[Musique]
bonsoir à tous place-publique vous
propose ce soir un magazine édifiant sur
le chlordécone le chlordécone comme
jamais vous n'en avez entendu parler car
il ya de nouveaux éléments qui
apparaissent certains sont plus précis
dix huit mille hectares de terres
chlordécone et en martinique cette un
peu plus de la moitié de notre
territoire
14% des enfants nés prématurément c'est
une fois et demie plus qu'en france
hexagonale
et puis 600 nouveaux cas de cancer de la
prostate chaque année en martinique la
martinique qui se place première au rang
mondial juste devant la norvège
alors sommes nous en train de vivre un
scandale sanitaire étouffé en martinique
voici l'anc est signée cécile marc et
des belles roses et olivier auguste
c'est déjà presque de l'histoire
le chlordécone un pesticide interdit aux
états unis dès 1976 et qui de dérogation
en trafic de lobbyisme agricole en
ministre complaisant sera saupoudrer sur
les plantations martiniquaise et
guadeloupéenne des années 70 jusqu'à
parfois début 2000
dix-huit mille hectares de terres
agricoles polluées 56% des cours d'eau
les trois quarts des aliments contaminés
600 ans avant d'en être débarrassé mais
dans 600 ans quel sera l'état de santé
de la population cancer prématurité
troubles cognitifs l'épreuve des méfaits
du
s'accumulent face à cela la réaction des
autorités semblent faire fi du principe
de précaution
c'est déjà presque de l'histoire mais si
le scandale du chlordécone
[Musique]
elle est entrée dans la vie si désarmés
si petite elle peser 835 grammes et
mesure et 34 cm kara est né à 5 mois et
demi lorsque nous la voyons elle a déjà
sept mois et c'est la première fois
qu'elle va tt sa maman une maman de 27
ans lauriane qui ne s'attendaient pas à
une telle épreuve perd son premier
enfant le premier jour c'est vrai que
quand j'allais vu j'ai fondu en larmes
c'est vrai que c'était dur de l'avoir
dans sa couveuse
c'est vrai que sa taille sa couleur
sa façon d'être parce qu'en fait ne
bougeait pas et palézieux
donc c'était peut-être difficile très
difficile par la suite il a fallu que je
manque de courage et de patience que je
sois fente plus donné cette force aussi
j'ai compris que se battait pour vivre
qu'il fallait que je la compagnie
l'un des responsables du calvaire de
kara c'est peut-être tout simplement
ceci le chlordécone l'enquète timoun
diligentée par l'inserm a mis les choses
au point dès 2014
mille mamans ont été suivis par les
équipes du professeur multigner
l'exposition maternelle au chlordécone a
été retrouvée associée de manière
significative à une durée raccourcie de
grossesse ainsi qu'à un risque augmenté
de prématurité puis et maman du
chlordécone dans le sang plus il y as
d'accouchement prématuré
un mois d'attentes avant de pouvoir
enfin prendre son bébé dans les bras des
perfusions une assistance respiratoire
pour aider les petits poumons pas encore
formé à respirer c'est la lourde réalité
des enfants prématurés
le service néonatalogie de la maison de
la mère et de l'enfant s'occupe de toute
l'année les prématurés représentant
martinique 14 % des naissances contre 7
% dans l'hexagone et dans son malheur
kara a eu de la chance les problèmes
autour de cantine est autour de cinq
points sont d'abord là le taux de survie
ne survienne pour de 40 60 % c'est assez
variable de forcément ces deux très
petits chiffres on en a que quelques uns
heureusement par an mais le risque de
décès est majeur quand on compare par
rapport à la métropole
on a à peu près un toqué entre une fois
et demie et deux fois celui de la
métropole
[Musique]
les ennuis de kara ne sont peut-être pas
fini ti moun a également révélé que les
enfants testés accusaient des retards de
développement moteur et cognitifs ils
retiennent moins vite au plus de
difficultés à effectuer correctement des
gestes comme tenir un crayon ou tourner
des pages le chlordécone a même un
impact sur le développement du corps
relève le chef de file de l'étude timoun
le professeur matinée n'a observé
quelque chose que je n'ai pas encore
plus clair c'est des différences de
trajectoire
c'était la vitesse avec laquelle
finalement qu'on grandit et on augmente
de poids entre la naissance et l'âge de
18 mois on avait eu des parcours
différents vous ce qu'on appelle
parcours différencié en fonction de
l'exposition au chlordécone et en plus
avec des effets que différentiel selon
le sexe de l'enfant
les différences de projet table de
croissance qu'on a observés ne sont pas
toujours constant que parfois ça se
traduit par une augmentation du poids
parfois par une réduction de la paille
[Musique]
les effets obésité troubles moteurs
troubles cognitifs sont ils rêvaient
ou pas on l'espère la réponse devrait
tomber l'année prochaine avec la
publication des résultats des 600
enfants qui ont tous atteint l'âge de 7
ans
les femmes enceintes les enfants des
publics particulièrement sensible qui
gagnerait à faire l'objet d'une
prévention spécifique
d'autant que la contamination est
générale c'est ce que révèle une enquête
canaries une enquête de 2013 terminée il
ya un an et demi mais toujours pas
publié dans son intégralité
est ce parce que les chiffres risque
d'affoler nous avons pu nous la procurer
en guadeloupe 95% des personnes testées
avaient du chlordécone dans le sang en
martinique 92 et 19 % des enfants
dépasser la dose toxique
[Musique]
devant toutes ces nouvelles données il
paraîtrait logique de protéger davantage
la population qu'en 2008 où les normes
ont été fixés c'est pourtant précisément
le contraire qui est en train de se
passer
malgré les contrôles réguliers à
l'abattoir départemental et à l'abattoir
vous êtes là deux trois fois par semaine
qu'est ce que vous allez faire là
maintenant donc pour le plan chlordécone
je vais faire des prélèvements leurs
différentes matrices pour contrôler la
contamination de la carte bleue dans
l'abattoir les services de l'adav
contrôle depuis 2003 tous les animaux
abattus
ils vérifient nom que la viande soit 100
chlordécone mais qu'elle ne dépasse pas
le taux autorisé
cela fait partie des mesures prises pour
protéger la population avec les
interdictions de pêche la filtration de
l'eau potable et les contrôles des
végétaux en 2017
les animaux sont classés par risques et
shuttle marc thierry que deux
produisent donc des bovins sont connus
par les services vétérinaires
et ils ont été caractérisés en fonction
du risque qui présente de présenter des
animaux non conformes
donc on applique un plan de contrôle qui
est variable en fonction du risque que
présentent les cheptels pluie le cheptel
présente un risque de contamination que
le contrôle que nous on fera à
l'abattoir sera important un dispositif
qui sécurise l'approvisionnement en
supermarché depuis le début de l'année
il a été rendu plus rapide
c'est désormais sur le foie que ce fonds
la majorité des contrôles là je vais le
conditionner pour de laboratoire va
venir chercher
sera analysée dans les trois jours
le problème c'est que la réglementation
sur laquelle se basent ces contrôles
pour déclarer une viande propres à la
consommation ou non a changé
[Musique]
et une fois ci en octobre 2017 à la ctm
se tient un colloque de santé
environnementale entre les allocutions
sur la qualité de la veille moustiques
un fonctionnaire de la rs eric baudart
lâché une petite bombe en mars 2013 et
une modification de la nex de ce
règlement qui fixait les modalités de
contrôle et les parties auxquelles
s'applique est l'airé les maires dans
les denrées carnet terrestre et la lmr
applicables à la grèce a été rendue
applicable à tous les organes tels que
mis sur le marché
traduit en français cela signifie que
l'europe a autorisé une augmentation du
taux de chlordécone dans certains
aliments cinq fois plus qu'avant dans la
viande
dix fois plus qu'avant dans la volaille
la petite bombe explose deux mois plus
tard lorsque l' agence de sécurité
sanitaire anses s saisi en février 2017
estime que sénarens booster ne pose
aucun problème
elle semble en tout cas en poser à l'est
risquaient levage des morts en dessous
du risque légumes puisque il ya la
concentration dans l'animal l'animal ce
contaminant et vous avez les éléments là
dans la brochure
c'est très difficile de répondre à cette
question
[Musique]
on ne sait pas si ça lui a posé problème
le ministre de l'agriculture stéphane
travert en visite en martinique nous
accorde en tout cas une interview sur la
question avant toutefois de la des
commandes et au tout dernier moment il a
parlé des produits phytosanitaires le
chlordécone est ce qu est ce que vous
estimez qu'on est toujours bien protégé
sachant que les normes résiduelles ont
augmenté merci madame vous n'avez rien à
dire sur cette question nation votre
ministère qui a autorisé jeudi ce que je
vais vous dire moi la merci rien à dire
donc côté gouvernement mais après la
décision de l'agencé de sécurité
sanitaire en décembre deux spécialistes
font immédiatement connaître leur
désaccord
le professeur multigner responsable de
toutes les études santé et chlordécone
qui parle d' imprudence sur notre
antenne et voici ce qu'on pense le
professeur william dab
c'est l'ancien président du conseil
europe santé environnement au sein de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et l'ancien président du conseil
scientifique chlordécone études
disponibles
on est très que le partie non
négligeable de la population les
antilles françaises étaient déjà au
dessus des valeurs limites d'exposition
ce qui d'ailleurs assez étonnant encore
au portant on peut constater une telle
situation il ultra arrive en population
générale
c'est quand même tout à fait
exceptionnel quand il ya une partie de
la population qui dépasse celle un
recommandé notamment des enfants ce qui
pose évidemment à cette année de deux
questions pour pour leur santé future
non je trouve que c'est de décision qui
a été prise
lui ne ne protège pas correctement la
population les antilles françaises
vis à vis de l'exposition au chlordécone
en pratique avec les nouvelles normes
si les denrées sont au maximum autorisé
et pas davantage
voici les quantités que vont manger
chaque jour un adulte de 80 kg 2 kg de
légumes des kilos de poissons 400 g de
viande 200 g de volaille
évidemment pour un enfant qui pèse 4
fois moins il faut également diviser les
quantités par quatre
[Musique]
à part les bébés et les mamans une autre
partie de la population est
particulièrement vulnérable au
chlordécone les aînés et surtout ceux
qui pendant des années ont touché le
produit les ouvriers agricoles
quand nous commençons notre reportage
nous cherchons d'abord des données sur
ce public
en vain à croire qu'il n'existe pas ou
n'ont aucun problème dans le nord
atlantique la région la plus polluée
réside aussi bon nombre d'ouvriers
agricoles
samuel barthel existe bel et bien il
habite on l'aura un quartier sous bois
il a un cancer de la prostate un
problème à la 10e' également il ya
travaillé 37 dans la banane c'est
peut-être lui qui existait à l'époque
ouais ça faisait partie du boulot voilà
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez d'intervalle à nous
il faut être polyvalent
j'ai fait les juifs et le débat d'âge
les tonnages du cheval et de la banane
grh et les plots quand vous avez entendu
parler pour la première fois du
chlordécone et des et du fait que
c'était dangereux qu'est ce que vous
vous êtes dit mais il était déjà tard
dans sa maison au bord de la mer
monsieur bart elle vit une vie
équilibrée
il élève des poules sa terre et
peut-être scène
mais si elle est contaminée ses
volailles ils le seront également
sait-il que leurs yeux peuvent monter
jusqu'à 25 fois la norme et que leur foi
aliments santé par excellence est aussi
riche en chlordécone qu'en faire et peut
monter jusqu'à 174 fois la norme le
sait-il lui qui devrait éviter tout
nouvel apport
sur la rivière grande anse qui borde son
terrain les canards du voisin
s'abreuvent et aval peut-être leur dose
quotidienne de pesticides
sur les plantations le cancer de la
prostate on en parle à peine s'il vers
l'iss les chefs d'equipe à l'habitation
du obouo maregu il nous le confirme ils
n'osent pas en parler parce que il ne
pense pas que c'est lié directement au
chlordécone
mais dans cette région il y en a
beaucoup oui est-ce que vous en
connaissez des gens qui ont le cancer de
la prostate ou qu'ils ont eu
oui parce que monter a eu des mots durs
à celle de la prostate
donc quand vous discutez avec des gens
qui ont le cancer de la prostate est ce
qu'ils savent d'où ça vient non pas
forcément parce que parce que il parce
que quand même si des fois il parle
d'aliments il parle de plaies comme
quelqu'un qui prenne exemple du bon
qu'elle ne fume pas mais il a quand même
à quoi sert le sco n'a eu sur la zone
est là pour travailler pour qu'ils
parlent eux quand vous me dites il ya
plein de gens qui l'ont oui a déjà mais
c'est a beau et c'est à visage caché
qu'une autre ancienne ouvrière accepte
de nous parler nous l'appellerons denise
elle a commencé à travailler dans la
banane à l'âge de 18 ans elle déclare un
cancer du sein à 58 ans sa meilleure
amie également ouvrière est morte d'un
myélome leucémie son mari à 69 ans il
est atteint d'une leucémie
j'ai mis un peu de tout il ya le clos
des probables pour juillet encore que
j'ai mis là je ne peux pas certifier que
c'est claude école de foot j'y voyais je
sais pas lequel
j'aime les bons de conduite je ne peux
pas certifier dire si le chlordécone qui
m'a fait ça si c'est celle là puisque je
m'étais tour ben bongo contre faisait le
nettoyage du manga il y avait des
produits qu'on passait dans le tri qui
avait pas de bonne augure
on sait faire il ya une fois ma copine à
moi à passer le produit
et puis le gars qui fait c'est le catch
et bessat prix du feu ça fait deux
fleuves real on ne sait pas si la
qu'elle quittait pas bon
oh
et dans cette région du north atlantic
un médecin le docteur mcnee alerte
depuis déjà plusieurs années
l'augmentation des cancers
c'est sous des cancers du sein des
consoles la prostate ap les pathologies
de civilisation des maladies
puisque la confection devenu fois
[Musique]
un rapport d'évaluation officielle
relever dès 2011 l'injustice faite aux
travailleurs de la banane
[Musique]
près de vingt ans après la découverte du
problème chlordécone pas plus samuel que
le père de sylvère pas plus de nier ce
que son ami ont fait l'objet d'une
attention particulière
[Musique]
maison des syndicats ici se trouve l'une
des organisations historique des
ouvriers agricoles la cgt m
comme toute la martinique les
syndicalistes ont découvert le scandale
du chlordécone dans les années 2000
ils commencent d'ailleurs à s'inquiéter
de la santé de ses employés des bananes
rit jamais parler de la pollution que
pouvait provoquer les produits
phytosanitaires sur les ouvriers on n'a
jamais cherché à savoir par des examens
par des contrôles par la mise en oeuvre
d'une politique parce que c'est un petit
peu ce ce problème là il fallait engager
une enquête de santé publique et notre
proposition c'était de dire mais mettons
en place une équipe une plate forme
pluridisciplinaire mettons en plus
glisser priorité toutes ces
organisations tous ces organismes de
manière à ce que on sorte quelque chose
et qu'on fasse les ouvriers sortir par
le haut dans cette situation on nous a
répondu personne ne nous arrivons
dans ces années là les ouvriers
agricoles étaient officiellement 4000 en
comptant les petits exploitants cela
représente plus de vingt mille personnes
que sont ils devenus combien d'entre eux
sont malades
la seule enquête disponible à ce jour
réalisé en 1999 sur les salariés
agricoles de la banane en guadeloupe
avait relevé un niveau de chlordécone
dans leur sens quatre fois supérieure à
la population générale
pour une prise en charge la cgtm a
multiplié les démarches lettre au
ministre au préfet jusqu'à aujourd'hui
tout est restée lettre morte
considère le salarié agricole confronté
à ces empoisonnements comme un salarié
normal et ça c'est pas normal
une enquête de recensement existerait
mais selon la réponse désormais
familière on ne peut pas communiquer les
résultats
elle n'est pas finie alors nous sommes
allés voir à la sécu les choses ont bien
changé depuis l'époque du chlordécone
désormais on apprend aux ouvriers à se
protéger et il existe des maladies
professionnelles déclarées dans la
banane elle concerne les troubles
musculo-squelettiques la pathologie
professionnelle auxquels sont vraiment
exposés les salariés du secteur agricole
c'est vraiment la manutention de charge
load léger conçu postures contraignantes
et les gestes répétitifs
je rappelle quand même pu que régime de
bananes pèse environ 50 kg pour déclarer
une maladie professionnelle
il faut que celle-ci soit inscrite dans
un registre c'est ainsi que dans
l'agriculture
il existe depuis 2012 une reconnaissance
de la maladie de parkinson comme lié aux
pesticides
mais malgré la liste impressionnante de
pesticides relevé par la cgt m
une surprise nous attend à des
pathologies qu'il ne compte pas tout à
fait aux critères des tableaux et ce
comité se réunit pour pouvoir aux
reconnaître quand même certaines
pathologies professionnelles sur ma
question est très précise est ce que en
martinique il y avait aucun ne serait ce
qu'un cas de maladie professionnelle
liée aux pesticides non
[Musique]
ni le cancer du sein ni la leucémie dont
souffrent denise son ami et son mari
n'ont pour l'instant été relié
scientifiquement au chlordécone
des études sont en cours mais pour le
cancer le plus répandu en martinique
celui de la prostate
l'étude karuprostate semblait pourtant
avoir mis les choses au clair
paru en 2011 elle a établi de façon
imparable le lien entre chlordécone et
cancer de la prostate dès qu'apparaît
une élévation du chlordécone dans le
sens vous élevez votre risque si on
admet que quand vous n'avez pas de
chlordécone dans le sens vous avez un
risque un d'avoir un cancer de la
prostate et bien dès que le chlordécone
commence à pouvoir être mesurée dans le
sang vous élevez légèrement votre risque
et ça commence à être quelque chose de
très significatif un de passer d'un
risque un un risque de voir survenir
quelque chose
c'est un événement très important
augmentation du risque précise l'étude
est significative lorsque les
concentrations mesurées atteignent la
valeur de 1 microgramme par litre de
sang
pour rappel les oublie
récolter stengel ou dépassé de 4 à 100
fois ses valeurs
alors pourquoi cette différence de prise
en charge officielle entre le par
kingson de la vigne et le cancer de la
banane à cause d'un simple petit mot
causalité on ne considère pas encore
officiellement que le chlordécone soit
la cause ou l'une des causes du cancer
il aurait sans doute fallu une étude
supplémentaire agnès buzyn aujourd'hui
ministre de la santé alors responsable
de l'institut national contre le cancer
était bien d'accord en 2014 nous avons
le souci de mettre en place des études
scientifiques pour comprendre en fait la
caractéristique de cet ancien de
prostate aux antilles une étude
similaire à 40 prostate est donc lancée
en martinique mahdi prostate
les résultats commencent à tomber
pointant apparemment dans la direction
du chlordécone et ses crédits lui sont
brutalement retirée quelques mois après
l'interview par là-même agnès buzyn un
coup de théâtre qui a laissé un goût
amer aux chefs de file des études mathy
prostate aurait pu confirmer ou infirmer
en martinique ce que nous avions observé
en guadeloupe
malheureusement cette étude n'a pu se
dérouler jusqu'au bout par arrêt des
financements on aurait voulu empêcher de
conclure de manière plus consistante
on n'aurait pas mieux fait la
reconnaissance du chlordécone comme
cause du cancer de la prostate avec à la
clé d'éventuelles indemnisations
notamment pour les ouvriers agricoles
restent en bout de course une décision
politique qui n'a jamais été pris ce
[Applaudissements]
concert précoce est particulièrement
agressif prématurité troubles de
l'apprentissage obésité le chlordécone
est un perturbateur endocrinien c'est à
dire qu'il peut potentiellement créiez
des pubertés précoces autisme retards
mentaux et cancers liés aux hormones
autant dire que les mauvaises nouvelles
risquent de s'accumuler et là encore
seul une décision politique pourrait
changer la donne
quand une conférence sur la santé se
tient à madiana en fin d'année dernière
les médecins martinique et supplie
presque qu'on arrête les frais qu'il ya
trois mois une passe en deux temps parce
que c'est cette femme aérien est
subitement à développer fact
pathologique et jusqu à savoir le chu
n'a pas pu établir nos styles sauf que
c'est un cancer foudroyant qui a
bousillé toutes sa colonne vertébrale et
elle a souffert atrocement ces cas là
deviennent de plus en plus fréquents on
se dit on ne peut pas rester sans rien
faire et le constat montre pas et c'est
dans un costard cannelle
comment dix neuf 19 mycograb il dit
qu'aussi conforme c'est à lui que l'on a
dit miguel pouvons manger avec nous même
si landing amusant non de ce fait si ce
n'est pas comme le nôtre pesticides
c'est un perturbateur endocrinien et
vous savez ce qu'on entend partout mais
naturellement aujourd'hui fière de vous
attaquer par les jouets les nations
matin donne ce que vous savez surtout
quand c'est des petites baisses cumulées
problème c'est que je fais mon marché le
dimanche sur marché france je ne sais
absolument pas dans ce que je demande
comment dirais-je a produit quelconque
je ne sais absolument pas d'où tu viens
je ne sais absolument pas qu'elle comme
dirait une enquête complexe il a été
cultivé et donc il se peut que
quotidiennement fait mer de l'est
dimanche
je rajoute un petit peu mal aux copies
explique est donc l'un des codes le
roundup de tout ce que vous voulez
cinquante écoulera ces polymères sans
sourciller
depuis presque dix ans malgré les
résultats des études la politique de
santé n'est pas réévaluer l'information
au public à elle disparu
les lanceurs d'alerté comme l'âme cesse
l'association médicale de sauvegarde de
la santé préconise un certain nombre de
mesures pour le cancer de la prostate
alertés les hommes à partir de 40 ans
afin d'éviter les diagnostics trop
tardif
c'est vrai qu'on a quand même des
typologies cancer qui sont préoccupantes
qui interroge notamment des cancers chez
les sujets plus jeunes
et puis avec des formes plus agressif et
certaines tumeurs notamment d'un cancer
du sein des cancers du côlon et du
cancer de la prostate fait tout au débat
de santé publique je pense qu'on y
travaille je pense que les autorités
nationales les autorités les jeunes à
travailler dessus à savoir est-ce qu'on
doit expérimenter des dépistages à des
âges plus plutôt que c'est à dire pas
attendre forcément des ascona je
rappelle quand même qu'il n'existe pas
de dépistage organisé du cancer de la
prostate et l'archos 7 explique ça c'est
une expérimentation peut-être à conduire
en martinique pour la consommation
plutôt que de renvoyer les gens à une
importation encore moins sécurisés créer
un circuit labellisé sans chlordécone
une hypothèse que magali jeanne noyer le
sueur du cirad qui étudie la pollution
des terres depuis 15 ans croit possible
est ce que l'on peut imaginer arriver un
jour en martinique à la belle 0
chlordécone comme moi je pense que oui
parce qu'en fait toutes les parcelles ne
sont pas polluées en chlordécone donc il
ya quand même une quantité possible de
surfaces cultivables non polluée est
donc là on pourrait mettre en place ce
type de label et enfin à coller le
recommandent les études scientifiques
depuis déjà plusieurs années
protéger la mère et l'enfant on aurait
cherché une solution pour protéger les
enfants du chlordécone quand on a
commencé à faire les premiers plans en
2007 que nous aurions déjà gagné dix ans
il ne faut pas assez froid on a besoin
d'en savoir plus pour mettre en oeuvre
des actions de prévention les arguments
nécessaires pour déclencher immersion de
prévention de grande envergure sans s'y
coller le club et comme il faut bien
réaliser que c'est pas une affaire du
passé
le problème de santé publique du club
école
le problème est bien devant nous les
taux de chlordécone dans l'au-delà capot
et les nappes phréatiques ne sont pas en
baisse mais en augmentation
le pesticide pourrait même avoir des
impacts génétique après plusieurs
générations d'exposition mais en
l'absence de tout nouvel apport un
humain ceux des contaminants seulement
quatre ans pour les générations futures
nous pouvons encore éviter le pire
[Musique]
notre premier interlocuteur dossier
était évidemment l'état l'état que nous
avons beaucoup passent haussier à cette
enquête mais qui a décliné l'invitation
de ce jour et nous le regrettons
fortement car qui mieux que l'état peut
répondre à ces questions santé publique
cécile marc vous nous avez rejoint si
vous qui avez réalisé donc cette enquête
durant près de trois mois
quelle a été la collaboration de l'état
alors au début cette collaboration était
tout à fait satisfaisante on nous a
proposé pas mal de reportages on nous a
ouvert des portes notamment à la daf on
voit voile agricole on voit pour fait ce
reportage à l'abattoir avec les légendes
l'agriculture l'état était ok pour
communiquer sur les actions que l'état
fait car il ya des actions de l'état l'a
pas d'inertie
soyons clairs alors c'est difficile de
répondre à cette question comme dit
quelqu'un dont le reportage
en fait il ya des actions de l'état qui
ont été mis en place à partir des années
2000 jusqu'à environ 2012 ses actions ce
sont les contrôles de la viande le
contrôle de l'est des légumes contrôle
de l'eau contrôle des terres donc il y
avait une véritable mobilisation de
l'état qui a été mis en place seulement
depuis 2012
plus rien dès qu'on a commencé à parler
des limites maximales de résidus et
notamment les siennes interviewé le
ministre de l'agriculture et faire les
choses à sa façon un petit peu durcies
et compliqué jusqu'à et 7 refus de
communiquer que vous venez de signaler
qu'il faudrait quand même je pense
mettre en parallèle avec la situation
qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans l'hexagone
avec les eaux la clé lait lactalis
vous avez une crise sanitaire dans
l'hexagone vous avez des conférences de
presse des ministres où est la
communication est quand même assez
régulière notamment eric gaillard et
kaunas et nous donc c'est difficile de
comprendre que nous on nous refuse un an
alors vous avez eu en tout cas des
interviews du monde scientifique de
france hexagonale excuses ont été
surpris de vos questions de ce thème qui
revient à la surface
alors non parce que pour eux ce thème
n'a jamais quitté la surface c'est un
petit peu le paradoxe avec nous avec le
public martiniquais
on a l'impression effectivement que le
chlordécone a disparu des consciences
mais il n'a pas du tout disparu ni des
études scientifiques ni des organistes
les scientifiques continuent à faire des
études très importante le professeur
multigner notamment qui revient à
plusieurs reprises dans dans le
reportage mène cinq ou six études sur
des tas de domaines différents notamment
l'impact du chlordécone sur le foie
l'impact du chlordécone sur le cancer du
sein
l'impact est jusque là on déconne sur le
cancer de la prostate c'est déjà terminé
tout près donc
il ya les et les scientifiques comme ils
sont toujours au travail
simplement les informations ne reviendra
à la population est-ce qu'on a parlé de
l'île tard de la communication de l'état
mais est ce que ça a été évident
également de trouver des témoignages
et non il faut reconnaître c'était à un
moment avec eddy bellerose qui a
collaboré avec moi sur sur ce thème on
s'est dit mais on al'impression donc
était sur quelque chose d'illégal
c'est vraiment très paradoxal c'est que
on s'est retrouvé avec des gens qui nous
donnaient des rendez-vous et qu'il est
décommandé à la dernière minute on s'est
retrouvé avec des gens qui nous disaient
personne ne veut parler alors notamment
sur le jeu cancer de la prostate des
ouvriers agricoles c'est absolument
extraordinaire il a fallu qu'on qu'on
aille sur place pour avoir enfin des
témoignages ou parce qu'il n'y a pas de
recensement finalement ou alors y en a
un autre qui n'a pas payé en a un que
son client n'a paraît-il qu'on a ce
qu'on n'a jamais plus on n'a jamais pu
voir le résultat
et puis même les ouvriers agricoles même
sont réticents à parler ça est en fait
cette réticence je trouve est aussi ce
qui ce qui permet à ce qu'aujourd'hui on
ne parle quasiment plus de chlordécone
comme si c'était un problème du passé
alors que pas du tout non seulement ce
n'est pas un problème du passé on qu'on
l'expliqué dans le reportage
mais c'est un problème du futur parce
que les impacts sanitaires ne feront que
s'aggraver si rien n'est fait j'aimerais
quand même pour parle de ses enquêtes
que vous avez dévoilé notamment sur la
partie chiffrée de l'enquète canaries
alors comment ça s'est passé comment
avez-vous ils ces documents ne sauverait
pas dévoiler nos sources effectivement
bien sûrement pas c'est quand même assez
édifiant de voir que les autorités ne
communiquent pas ces résultats à la
population qui les attend et qui les
oublis pratiquement alors il ya
plusieurs enquêtes qui sont terminées
qui sont en cours en cours d'analysé dit
on pour ce qui est de l'enquète ki moon
le professeur multigner est en étant
très ouverts par ailleurs donc je vais
paraître en doute sa parole mais c'est
vrai que les cool effectivement ça fait
déjà un petit moment qu'elle est
terminée
pour le deuxième et dernier volet des
enfants de 7 ans et puis cette fameuse
enquête canaris alors on nous dit oui
mais on l'a publié regarder en décembre
pour descendre on a commencé le
reportage en octobre regarder en
décembre l'agent cela ne sais ça fait un
peu oublier le résultat a lancé sa
publié le résultat mon cesse autorités
on se sert nationale à l'autorité
sanitaire nationale mais le résultat les
résultats de l'enquêté de l'étude qui
n'est pas publié dans son intégralité et
notamment les chiffres qui sont très
très parlants que je dois donner
colonnes dans le reportage ne sont pas
publiés donc oui en fait j ai publié
cécile pardonnez moi c'est juste les
recommandations c'est ça les
recommandations de santé et puis
effectivement c'est cette espèce de
pavés où vous pouvez savoir à peu près
si vous lisez tout pavés ou est-ce qu'il
faut acheter votre poisson ou est-ce
qu'il faut acheter votre poulet ou
est-ce qu'il fonctionne jolies pages à
peu près 150 mille pages pour faire pour
faire des courses et pas très pratique
donc ça c'est publié en revanche les
chiffres qu'on a donnés sont pas publiés
on va pas aller jusqu'à dire que il ya
une volonté de cacher mais de toute
évidence la communication sur le
chlordécone s'est interrompue depuis
environ 2012 c'est à dire depuis déjà
quatre ans merci beaucoup
cécile pour toutes ces précisions merci
alors quels sont les effets du
chlordécone sur notre santé dr jose
pélage présidente de l'âme cesse
martinique bonjour l'âme cesse c'est
l'association martiniquaise de
sauvegarde de l'environnement et de la
santé
à partir de quel taux le chlordécone a
des conséquences néfastes sur notre
organisme
le chlordécone a toujours des
conséquences néfastes sur l'organisme
quel que soit le taux on peut définir un
taux à partir duquel certaines
manifestations sont plus fréquentes que
l'autre avec un taux relativement bas de
0,02 microgrammes par litre
vous pouvez avoir une conséquence sur le
cerveau mais vous pouvez avoir à partir
d'un taux plus élevés une action sur le
sperme
disons que quel que soit le taux vous
avez une action sur notre santé et les
donnes infinitésimale les doses
infinitésimales peux vous donner à la
génération suivante une obésité ou un
diabète donc vous voyez que le taux
dangereux de donkey 2
on donne aux organismes profitent des
parents à leur enfant et entraîne des
troubles métaboliques justement ces
effets sont ils visible sur notre
physique alors ses effets sont visibles
sur notre état de santé
quand vous regardez l'état de santé de
la population martiniquaise et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui tire la sonnette
d'alerme c'est que nous avons un nombre
explosif de cancer de la prostate
oui si sens du jeu car kit ou marrant et
la martinique premier au premier rang
d'un nouveau cas mais en 1981 on en
avait moins de 200 voyez donc on a quand
même depuis 30 ans une augmentation
exponentielle alors qu'on dit quand même
j'aimerais préciser on dit quand même
que le cancer de la prostate est liée
aux gènes alors écoutez la liste noire
des personnes de couleur
un certain nombre d'études montrent que
c'est plus fréquent chez les noirs mais
ça a été fait chez les noirs américains
mais vous savez que les noirs américains
aussi était dans les plantations
je rappelle qu'elle est le deuxième pays
au rang mondial c'est la norvège
oui c'est vallier ses paliers cc c'est
un rapport aux maintenances et le plus
en plus que le le gène évolue aussi avec
l'environnement la transmission du code
de l'adn est variable aussi en fonction
de l'environnement qui entoure le la
cellule au moment de sa réplication et
puis l'enquète karuprostate qu'on a vu
dans ce don ce magazine aussi prouve
bien que le lien a été établi le lien
était établi si vous regardez
l'incidence standardisée du cancer de la
prostate dans les autres pays de la
caraïbe qui sont des populations noires
vous n'avez pas une incidence de ce1 de
200 pour cent mille habitants comme vous
avez ces perturbateurs endocriniens que
représentent ils alors ce sont des
molécules chimiques en général mais vous
avez des métaux lourds également qu'ils
sont perturbateurs endocriniens qui
étaient offerts avec nos hormones tout
le monde sait ce que sont nos hormones
on connaît beaucoup la thyroïde on
connaît beaucoup le pancréas
on oublie d'effroi que la grèce c'est
aussi une hormone c'est une cellule
hormonal donc ce sont des molécules qui
perturbe le bon fonctionnement ou bien
elles perdent tube la fabrication des
ormes
ou bien le père le tube l'action de ces
hormones sur la cible et ces
perturbateurs endocriniens ont de
lourdes conséquences sur notre santé
puisqu'il crée aussi de l'obésité de
l'obésité du diabète des cancers et
surtout ce qu'on oublie ce sont les
troubles neurologiques
on s'est rendu compte que ces
perturbateurs endocriniens sont des
perturbateurs neurologiques dans la
mesure où ils interfèrent la plupart du
temps avec l'hormone thyroïdienne
parce que selon wendy williams est la
seule hormones que nous avons qui
contient un halogène c'est-à-dire llyod
et cet iode est susceptible d'être
bouger d'être mobilisés par tout ce qui
contient ddd aussi d'aider des ions tu
les perds chlorure les perdreaux m'as tu
le paies et le le chlordécone parce
qu'il contient du clos donc par
l'intermédiaire de sept îles ont clos on
a souvent une action sur le cerveau mais
le lien de causalité de la pas encore
été établis notamment par exemple avec
l'obésité
ab certainement vous avez des études
vous avez beaucoup d'études qui montrent
le lien entre le chlordécone j'avais des
thèses avaient une thèse de qui a été
fait en 2012 sur le lien et qui a montré
le mécanisme par l'intermédiaire des
mitochondries
alors pourquoi l'état le gouvernement
fait la sourde oreille
écoutez je vous ai expliqué comment nous
avons tiré la sonnette d'alarmé auprès
de toutes les instances nationales et
régionales je me suis moi même déplacé à
plusieurs reprises pour rencontrer le
directeur général de la santé le
directeur de l'ensait ce pour expliquer
que nous avions
on sait ce qui est l'autorité de
sanitaires nationales agences que la
finale c'est un établissement public qui
fait des recherches pour le compte de
certains nombre de ministères dont le
ministère de l'agriculture et de la
santé et leur expliquer que si on
pouvait faire la sourde oreille pendant
un certain temps l'état sanitaire
aujourd'hui de la martinique permet de
faire le lien entre la pollution par le
chlordécone et là des jeunes est là
la dégénérescence de l'état sanitaire
notamment cancéreux métabolique
hydrologique il faut surtout parce que
la gravité aussi du chlordécone c'est
son action d'euros logique son action
sur le cerveau surtout des enfants en
développement je voudrais revenir quand
même sur la neige parce qu'il ya dans ce
dossier les informations vraiment
étonnante voire même l' agence vous
parler de la langue française française
pardon française qui est l' agence
nationale de sécurité sanitaire et qui
je le rappelle un je précise quand même
qui n'a absolument rien à voir avec
votre association une association parce
qu est une association wi lan c'est ce
qu'ils décident de réévaluer à la hausse
les lmr c'est à dire la limite maximale
de résidus de pesticides dans les
aliments
on est perdu et pas cette réévaluation à
la hausse
est ce que vous vous avez tenté une
explication écoutez moi j'ai cherché en
vain l'explication sans la trouver
d'autant plus que quand qui a vu le plan
chlordécone en 2007 2010 mais nous à le
plan chlordécone avait demandé au
conseil scientifique dont fait partie le
fait de donner un certain nombre de
recommandations
et parmi ces recommandations il y avait
la diminution la réduction de
l'exposition
donc si vous augmentez les données que
vous multipliez vous augmenter
l'exposition et vous multipliez le
risque c'est un empoisonnement au
goutte-à-goutte coûtait chaque terme est
tellement qu noter que je préfère ne pas
l'utiliser mais un empoisonnement
suppose aussi une attention donc on peut
difficilement parler d'un poids zone
mans mais il est certain que c'est un
mise en danger de la santé des
populations cette réévaluation je crois
qu'elle date de 2013 est ça est-ce que
vous avez pris contact avec lens s je
file 2013 non j'ai pris contact avec
lens s en 2015 en novembre 2015 j'ai été
j'ai demandé un rendez vous au directeur
général de l'ansés ce monsieur marc
mortueux à l'époque qui m'a fait
recevoir par son assistant et geôliers
laisse un dossier lui expliquant que
nous aurions vraiment aimé qu'il révise
un peu ces normes et qui on atteigne
progressivement
je pense que c'est difficile
effectivement de réorganiser tout pour
arriver aux héros plan d'économies fois
bof
justement on va te parlant de la filière
zéro chlordécone un peu plus tard on
rappelle que serait déposé un dossier en
demandant le collant 16 joue un peu sur
son autorité oui pour pouvoir arriver à
une réduction progressive du taux de
résidus dans les aliments mais au
contraire ils ont réévalué à la hausse
on rappelle quand même que le poulet
élevé en batterie est vendu dans le
commerce n'est pas contaminée selon vous
le boulet n'est pas contaminé la
contamination se fait par le sol donc
une fois que le poulet en sol il n'est
pas censé recevoir des de chlordécone
selon vous est ce qu il ya de la
complaisance de la part de l'état de la
part de certains lobbys écouter sans
accuser personne on peut l'imaginer
moi je crois que tout est un rapport de
force si vous avez devant vous quelqu'un
qui dit kiki qui se fait entendre vous
reculez mais si en face de vous vous
n'avez personne qui se fait entendre
effectivement il n'y a pas de raison de
ne pas défendre vos intérêts et c'est
pourquoi je crois que la solution à ce
problème vient de la population il faut
que la population exige qu'elle soit
respectée
qu'elles soient respectées je chantais
soit respectivement j'aimerais bien
avoir votre point de vue sur le refus de
l'état de participer à cette émission ce
soir
écoutez je pense que tous vos l'état à
des ordres aux 6,1 s'est laissée en est
maintenant quand on étudie ce dossier
que les verrous se situe très haut que
ce qui se situe très haut et sur place
on ne fait qu'exécuter des ordres
donc voilà dix ans après la mise en
place du premier plan chlordécone qui a
coûté près de 33 millions d'euros
est ce que l'état selon vous peut tenir
à ce jour une liste de produits 100 de
produits cesse de l'autre lors des
causes encore décoller et que tu es non
je crois qu'aujourd'hui vous n'avez
aucun label sans chlordécone
vous avez des produits dits conforme
c'est-à-dire qu'ils contiennent 20
microgrammes par kilo de chlordécone
donc c'est à partir du moment où ces
produits sont conformes
ils sont censés être autorisé à la
consommation maintenant vous savez que
de 20 microgrammes kg pour un produit
qui met quatre ans à s'éliminer c'est
une intoxication chronique forcément à
terme
alors justement comment être sûr
aujourd'hui
de ne pas empoisonner un petit peu
chaque jour avec l'étude canaris sous le
bras en allant faire ses courses se
rappelle que l'étude canaries c'est
quand même 158 pages comment comment
peut-on faire qu'on n'est jamais sûr
sauf si vous avez votre jardin personnel
que vous avez fait analyser votre côté
emploi dessus qui a pas eu un apport
extérieur de chlordécone même s'il n'ya
pas une bananeraie auparavant une fois
que vous avez zéro chlordécone vous
planter ce que vous voulez et là vous
êtes tranquille comment vous l'imaginez
justement cette filière 0 chlordécone
qui serait coûteuse pour l'état
forcément mais écoutez moi je pense que
c'est il faut d'abord beaucoup de bonne
volonté et de prise de conscience que la
situation était bon tente il ya 40% des
terres qui sont pas contaminés et bien
on réquisitionne ses 40%
vous savez les terres en friche dans
toutes les communes j'ai entendu que
monsieur letchimy demande qu'on puisse
faciliter la résolution des successions
pour toutes les terres qui ne sont pas
voilà où la succession est difficile moi
je fais je pense que les terres en
friche font partie de ces thèmes qui
sont abandonnés bardet des héritiers
multiples et que l'état pourrait
présenter ou que les communes pourraient
présenter et mettre ses terres la
disposition des jeunes agriculteurs de
la commune
ça nous ferait déjà une première filière
qui aurait ce qu'elle a ce qu'elle peut
en fonction du sol et on saurait que si
on achète ses produits du carbet le
cinquième du prêcheur sur une terre dont
ils ont déconné qu'on a la garantie de
n'être pas contaminés
quel est le sort de nos populations
selon vous dans les prochaines années si
rien n'est fait écoutez c'est un
cauchemar pour nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants le volet sanitaire guerre
ceux d'entre nous qui sont déjà adultes
qui sont en bonne santé malgré le
chlordécone lorsque le chlordécone ne
donne que risque c'est pas une certitude
à 100% qu'on aura une pathologie vous
avez simplement un risque mais certains
d'entre nous auront échappé au risque
mais rien ne dit que nos enfants ne
seront pas impactés en tout cas moi je
crois que si on ne prend pas la décision
aujourd'hui en 2018
nous laissons une bombe à retardement un
cauchemar que nos enfants parce que déjà
ils seront pas sur quel thème produire
ensuite nous aurons des enfants de plus
en plus diminué sur le plan cérébral
donc qui auront peut-être plus de
capacité à protester et voilà on nous
ravir question docteur jose plage avant
le plan marshall contre le chlordécone
en martinique
est ce qu'il est possible de réaliser
des prises de sons par exemple pour
vérifier le taux de chacun dans notre
sens alors il est toujours possible tous
ces deux savoie où la cheminée c'est un
des combats de l'homme cesse et nous
n'avons pas cessé de frapper à la porte
voix de la ctn soit de la rs faut
permettre que ces doses un choix
d'annoncés nous avons contacté un
certain nombre de filières qui pourrait
nous faire les deux à la condition
d'être certain qu'ils auront
suffisamment de prélèvements que ce soit
rentable parce que l'investissement
matériel et quand même coûteux et voilà
mais 17 heures réalisées ailleurs mais
déjà conscience est réalisable puisque
on a beau rateront départemental
d'analysés de martinique ont rappelé la
boîte renter bas ont fait l'événement
sous le symbole veut et sur le lait des
vaches de l'avion donc si vous voulez
l'analyse elle et elle et elle est
réalisable
c'est anna réalisable ailleurs aussi
elle est gentille voilà elle était avec
moi possible le matériel on le connaît
il s'agit simplement de payer de
financer les analystes voient la
recherche sur le terme honni donc si le
centre hospitalier voulait avoir une
antenne toxicologiques
ça aurait pu être fait aussi en ordre il
ya aussi une question de volonté
merci beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
dr jose plage alors que mettre dans nos
assiettes et avant tout sur tout dans
notre chariot en allant faire ses
courses pour éviter un empoisonnement au
quotidien je vous propose ces quelques
conseils avec cécile marais stéphane
petit frère tout d'abord il faut être
clair qu'il y à du chlordécone presque
partout mais certaines denrées sont si
pollués qu'on arrive à peine à le
détecter
c'est le cas de tous les aliments qui
pousse en l'air on va donc prendre des
mandarines ça tombe bien pour la période
tous les fruits qui poussent dans des
arbres oui oui les bananes aussi et
n'oublions pas notre avocat bilan du
panier 0 microgrammes
on va ensuite se rapprocher du rayon
volaille la viande commercialisée en
barquette ne contient aucun chlordécone
les animaux sont en effet élevées en
batterie ou dans des hangars pareil pour
les oeufs évidemment si vous souhaitez
du poulet fermier pour la qualité ou le
respect des animaux
vous n'aurez d'autre choix que de
prendre le risque d'ingérer les 200
microgrammes par kilo désormais
autorisés voire plus puisqu'il n'ya pas
d'étiquetage dédié continuons notre
marché dans les végétaux on se rapproche
un peu du sol on trouve donc un peu plus
de chlordécone dans les haricots les
piments les choux pommés ou encore les
poivrons mais même hors circuit contrôlé
la dose restent minimales toujours en
dessous des seuils un peu plus élevé les
légumes qui poussent sur le sol l'étude
courgettes giraumon et aussi de fruits
pastèque melons le pesticide étant
cependant concentrée dans la peau et à
faible dose
parlons à présent des légumes racines on
sait qu'ils sont susceptibles de
contenir beaucoup de chlordécone
ce que l'on sait moins c'est que les
producteurs ont fait de réels efforts et
désormais que ce soit en hyper ou en
marché nos patates douces chaudes chine
ou ignames dépasse très rarement les 20
microgrammes négo font des exceptions
l'autoproduction sur seul non contrôlée
[Musique]
quand on arrive aux protéines
les choses se compliquent grâce à la
modification du règlement européen la
viande vendue même en supermarché peut
contenir jusqu'à 100 microgrammes par kg
pour un enfant de 20 kg c'est un steak
de 100 grammes maximum par jour afin de
ne pas dépasser la dose autorisée et les
choses sont encore pire avec le foie
s'il est aujourd'hui correctement
contrôlés il a été vendu jusqu'à l'an
passé à des doses 2 300 microgrammes
or les circuits contrôler cela reste
l'un des aliments les plus fortement
chlore déconner de notre palmarès
à
et si les produits de la mer sont par
définition l'aliment santé partout dans
le monde
en martinique le constat est bien triste
thierry vivaneau ciric langouste
barracuda thazar volant affiche toujours
des dépassements fréquents lors des
contrôles certes modérée entre quarante
et soixante et onze ans son programme
mais très fréquent 57 % des prélèvements
sont positifs quant aux poissons et
espèce de rivière autant boire un verre
de chlordécone
il affiche toujours des taux explosif
jusqu'à 7296 microgrammes pour le
tilapia
merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi mme cette
émission place publique ce numéro
exceptionnel
édifiant sur le chlordécone qui je
l'espère pourra éveiller les consciences
très belle soirée à bientôt
[Musique]